for now
let's turn gears to one of the highest
profile remaining free agents a guy who
was linked to cam newton through march
april may and june because
a significant player a great player a
former number one overall pick in the
draft still can't find work jadavian
clowning available to be signed by
anyone
still
angelian clowney still not employed by
an nfl team we talked about him earlier
this week shireen in the aftermath of
the annika gawkway trade because i have
a very basic analysis that i'm still
trying to resolve if the vikings pay 12
million dollars for this year plus give
up a second round pick which
some in league circles will say is worth
8 million dollars when you're talking
about the value of a trade so that's 20
million right there
and then another pick on top of it a
fifth rounder or up to a third rounder
in 2022 what what is clowney worth
and you know if clowney's healthy and
again this is the cam newton dilemma if
healthy genuine clown is one of the most
disruptive forces in the nfl and there
are now reports that the saints are
pursuing genevieve and clowny the titans
and the seahawks still interested you
know i think what this comes down to is
how much money does jadavian clowney
really want how much will he play for
what is his bottom line below which he
says screw it i'm not going to sign a
contract i'm not going to go out there
and play
and and i think that's one of the
reasons why he currently doesn't have a
job with an nfl team but as we get
closer and closer to week one and he's
looking at game checks he may lose i
think that that it you know maybe it is
inevitable that he's gonna pick his best
spot and go
and he's got to do it now because he's
got to pass covet protocols he's got a
passive physical which we know he had
the core muscle surgery in the off
season so he's got to do it now and i
think this was always the intent after
he didn't get the big contract he
expected early in free agency was to sit
out training camp and sign before this
first week but it's got to be now it's
got to be this weekend if he's going to
play in that first game and be
disruptive as you said
which he against the pass his greatest
play ever of course was against the run
we remember it in college when he just
crushed uh the michigan running back the
michigan great running back and just
killed him um but he's very very good
against the run as well as the power he
thinks of him as a pass rusher shoot he
had three and a half sacks last season
so he's as good against the run as he is
against the pass and sometimes better
against the run than he is against the
pass but how good would this make the
saints if they can get yet another pass
rusher to go with davenport to go with
cam
this to me would make the saints right
up there if they're already the
favorites i think in the nfc but if they
get this guy too and playing tom brady i
i really like their chances to get after
the quarterback
let me be cynical and conspiratorial as
it relates to what the saints are doing
here
it very well could be
that as part of the bargaining
with alvin kamara the saints running
back the argument will be hey alvin we
got this money budgeted for you
and if you don't want it we're going to
spend it on jadabi and clowny so you you
better you better say yes to this deal
because the money's going away i recall
there was a time i think it was the
steelers way back in 2012 they were
trying to sign mike wallace remember him
it's amazing he's just another example
of one of these guys who was a great
player and then when he's gone you have
to stop and forget about it yeah i
remember mike wallace but mike wallace
wanted a contract and mike wallace
rejected what the steelers were offering
and so still said fine we'll give it to
antonio brown instead uh and even though
we're talking about guys at two
different positions i i i it look we've
been around the game long enough to know
that things like this happen that that
coaches will use whatever they have at
their disposal to get a guy to do what
they want the guy to do they want alvin
kamara to sign
and it would not surprise me if the
saints are feigning interest in janavian
county as part of a broader hey alvin if
you don't sign we are we are paying
someone else with the money that
otherwise would go to you so the money
that otherwise would go to you is going
nowhere and we're gonna have to revisit
this next year so now let's let's set
aside that possibility and assume that
they are interested in genevieve and
clowny that they truly may make a run at
him uh i i wonder on one level whether
or not it shows they they have concerns
about marcus davenport a guy they gave
up a lot of trade capital to get in the
first round a couple of years ago or
whether this is just let's fashion a
rotation of guys who are just going to
destroy opposing offensive lines either
way you know whoever gets cadavian
clowney if it's a contender
it it definitely bumps them up a level
or two and how we're gonna look at that
team's prospects for 2020.
yeah no doubt about it if the titans end
up with him he's probably their best
pass rusher despite the fact that he had
three and a half sacks last season i
think he fits right in in tennessee and
makes them a better
defense
for mike rabel and what he can do with
davion clowney because he's had him
before in houston he was there when he
was there so he knows what he's getting
in jadavion clowning and i think the
titans are a pretty good team but he
makes them even better and i think it's
the same with seattle i think he goes in
there and makes them a better team with
the pass rush and despite the fact again
that he only had three and a half
seconds they feel like he was disruptive
last year they liked him they wanted him
back but they wanted him back at their
price and and they weren't going to pay
any more than 15 million and he
may make less than 15 million now after
turning down that deal
and sharing you keep mentioning that he
only had three and a half sacks and
while that's factually accurate it shows
that you are not sufficiently versed in
the statistic that chris sims has
created we've submitted it to the elias
sports bureau in the hopes that they
will make it part of the official menu
of nfl statistics it's the f up the play
stat it's the thing that doesn't matter
and he has that
yeah in a tackle or a sack or an
interception or a fumble but what he
does is he blows such a hole in what the
offensive line is trying to do
that it's just a jailbreak to the ball
by other guys and that's what jadavian
clowney does whatever the offensive line
and the rest of the offense are planning
to do
when he is firing on all cylinders
he can destroy that and f up the play as
chris would say and i think the best
example of it was last year the monday
night game between the seahawks and the
49ers how dominant he was now he had i
think he had didn't have a touchdown in
that game and interception returned for
a touchdown yeah yeah
but but but beyond that it's what he
does playing and play out to just
completely disrupt everything and
anything an offense is trying to do the
question with him is staying healthy and
also you've got to manage him in
practice and that's what pete carroll
the seahawks coach was good at this
isn't a guy who needs a lot of practice
this is the guy who needs to be handled
physically and last year remember he was
unsigned as a franchise tag player with
the texans he wasn't part of the
offseason program wasn't part of
training camp
signed
his franchise tender at a slight
reduction from 15.97 down to 15 was
traded to the seahawks this weekend
labor day weekend of last year and still
was an impactful player for most of the
season until he developed the core
muscle problem the the the sports hernia
whatever whatever term they use now
there's so many different terms for our
hernia but he had that issue he played
with and it first really popped up in
the game against the 49ers on that
monday night and he managed it the rest
of the year but you know the seahawks
are still interested let's hear from
pete carroll the head coach the team
acknowledging
that even though he's still out there
he's still available the team that
employed him last year still has
interest in employing him this year
here's pete carroll from yesterday
are you guys still in contact with
jadavian clowny at all is there still is
the door still open on him at all always
competing
always competing
always competing i mean that's you know
thank you pete but yeah i mean they
haven't closed the door and uh and and
and they shouldn't close the door but
here's the thing
how much will they pay remember
there's that weird little device in free
agency where if the guy is still
unsigned at the time the window for
compensatory draft picks closes you can
do
the tender to continue to hold his
rights and if he does go somewhere else
you still get compensatory draft pick
consideration that's what the giants did
with marcus golden and the rule is you
have to offer the guy 10 percent more
than what his salary was last year so
the seahawks could have squatted on
genevieve and clowney for 16.5 million
they decided
that's too much and i've heard that for
clowney he refuses to play
at 15 million or less now will that
change this weekend i don't know but the
posture all along has been he's not
signing for 15 or less the browns
reportedly wanted him for 15.
so that's kind of where it has stood but
shireen everything changes now because
we're getting to the point where
whatever your salary is
every week that goes by when you're not
on the team is a significant chunk of
money that you've lost forever and is
never coming back so i'm starting to
feel like whether it's the seahawks the
titans the saints or someone else swoops
in out of nowhere to sign genevieve and
clowny i'm starting to feel like we're
getting close to the point where it's
got to happen and it's going to happen
and it just feels like the the clouds
are gathering for that uh for that
clowny signing to happen
and we're talking about these three
teams being interested i mean we heard
saints or all-out blitz whether that's
true or not as you said whether they
they're using that for bargaining chip
for
uh alvin kamara or not whatever but this
all out blitz the titans have apparently
been in on j'davian county talked to him
all along been interested in him all
along and the seahawks have left that
door open but is there the potential
there for another team to come out of
nowhere and swoop in and decide that
j'davion clowney is the guy that's going
to make a difference for us i don't see
one off the top of my head but do you
think there's another team that could
swoop in there and end up with you davey
and clowny
after what the patriots do with cam
newton i have been keeping an eye on
them when it comes to any of these free
agents who are still out there whether
it's earl thomas javien clowney i
thought they'd make a run at leonard
fournette there was a report that they
were interested i still think that that
was false and it was aimed at getting
the buccaneers to make the move and
that's the other side of this too will
there be
floated by clowney's camp at some point
this weekend a report that the patriots
are interested in clowning just to get
the deal done with someone else but but
yeah i think you pick any contending
team and they have to ask themselves if
they have the cash and cap space and
look if they don't have the cap space
they can they can find a way to create
some it's not all that hard to do it's
it's a cap problem like a math problem
you sit down with a compass and a ruler
and a pencil and you figure it out and
most teams can figure it out and make it
all fit under the cap but yeah and if
i'm clowny and look how long he's been
in the nfl at some point you want to put
yourself in a position to pursue a
championship so you know it won't
surprise
any team i'm i'm i'm braced at this
point
for any team that we loosely consider to
be a playoff team popping up out of
nowhere and getting this deal done and
beyond the playoff teams i've seen some
talk that the jaguars
with all that money that they have saved
by moving on from
uh yannick and gawkway and trading him
that maybe the jaguars would make a run
at jadavian clown it would some people
say why didn't you just keep in gawkway
well and gakwe didn't want to be there
that's why he didn't keep him and look
there
i've talked to a bunch of different
people about it and and the opinions are
mixed as to whether or not clowney is
better than in gawkway but i think that
people would admit that if clowney is
healthy if you know he's going to be
healthy you'd much rather have him than
yannick and gawkway and that gets back
to my original point if the vikings are
paying 12 million plus giving up a
second round pick plus another pick to
getting gawkway what does that translate
to for a free agent that you don't have
to give a draft pick to go sign and it
doesn't affect your compensatory draft
pick consideration i really do feel like
he should be able to get more than 15
million and that's what he's wanted and
uh if more teams get to the table that's
just going to drive up the the
possibility he's going to get that
number shireen
yeah and i think he would probably get
more to go to jacksonville but why would
if if you're to deviant clowning why
would you want to go to jacksonville i'm
just saying you want to go win a
championship and you're signing a
one-year deal anyway and the place to go
is one of the three teams we mentioned
seattle tennessee or new orleans so
jacksonville to me just seems a
far-fetched
reality unless they come in and just
offer way more than any other team and
you know he's going there for the money
and the potential to show something that
to other teams so he can hit free agency
in 2021 and go hey all right now pay me
you didn't pay me last year now payment
you've seen what i can do but he would
have to have that really huge here in
jacksonville uh to get that money but i
i think it's going to be one of those
three teams we talked about and i i i
just for some reason really think it's
going to be tennessee with rabel and
they've been in this thing all along um
they could have gotten this deal done a
long time ago they didn't but i still
find that somehow someway i i think
tennessee is going to get this deal done
and we're going to look at tennessee as
the favorite in that division
i'll go back to something that chris and
i discussed earlier this week in the
aftermath of the ingawkway trade and you
know sunday morning we wake up to the
news that in gaque will be traded to the
vikings and you have a reaction to that
it's like wow hey the vikings are making
their move and chris's reaction if we
had changed yannick and gawkway to j to
davey and clowney would have been holy
crap the vikings are making their move
and i think whoever ends up with clowney
that's the reaction we're gonna have
holy crap this team is going for it
they're throwing caution to the wind and
they're going for a potential huge
upside acknowledging that there's a
downside possibly that comes along with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports